Jennifer Lopez. She first kissed a male
dancer and then she went on to kiss a
female dancer. Is she Is she kissing all
these people? JLo raises eyebrows by
kissing not one but two of her backup
dancers. There were little spicy moments
in there. There are little spicy moments
in there. I hear the kisses are going
viral. Are they kissing?
Are they kissing? The lyrics say, "And
the devil's knocking at my door." This
is being played while she is making out
with a woman and a man and another woman
and another man. She went down the line
and she just said, "I'm kissing all
y'all. Hide your kids. Have your hide
your wives cuz they kissing everybody
out here." AMA, the American Music
Awards happened this week. Jennifer
Lopez was hosting.
Welcome to the American Music Awards.
And this year's AMA was a big deal
because it hadn't happened in I think
2023 and 2024 due to uh scheduling
shifts, changes in broadcast rights, but
finally it happened again and Jennifer
Lopez, this is her second time hosting
the show. And uh she she did a musical
performance, a kind of a metly in the
beginning of the show that has gone
absolutely viral on YouTube. So she did
a metly of 23 songs that were all
snippets from the 2024 most viral and
chart topping hits by other artists. So
she was mostly just performing her
dancing paying homage. So in like 3 days
has over a million views on her YouTube
channel and it's trending on YouTube for
music right now. So, I want to take a
look at a couple of clips of her
performance that's gone viral and then
let's let's talk about
it. Welcome to the multiverse of
tomorrow's American Music Awards. This
evening, you will experience such
sensations as joy, love, sex, dance, and
most
importantly, music. Music. Music.
Did you guys pick up on what's being
said? I'm sure there was a word Satan
flashed in there somewhere. I'm just
kidding. Did you say something like
dance, sex, joy, love? Sex. Yeah. In
what context? This is a place of Yes.
Yes. You're about to enter this place.
Joy, love, dance, sex. Yes. What does
sex have to do with music in like an
award show? That's a show. That is okay.
like what what am I getting into right
here? You know, most songs are written
about love, right? I mean, and most
dance moves are written because or
performs like Okay. Yeah. Especially
Sabrina Carpenter, by the way. She used
one of Sabrina Carpenters's songs,
Espresso, in here as well. We know what
she's about, you know. But this was the
beginning of the opening of the whole
AMA Awards and this beginning of her
performance. And this is how they open
the show. They're laugh. You're about to
enter the space. And you know, it's
interesting because joy and love are
actually words described in the fruits
of the spirit that God gives us as we
have a transformed heart. But here they
connect the words joy and love with sex.
And we know what kind of a sexuality
they portray in these shows and music,
right? This is not like there's no
offlimits sexuality. Yeah. Like it's
lust, but they connect that to
love and joy. But the Bible says God is
love, right? Very different. And true
definition of love is you wouldn't harm
someone or you wouldn't go, you know,
lie to them or cheat on them or all
those things that the ten commandments
describe. So it's kind of blending the
terminology without the reasoning behind
what makes love. Yeah. So uh you know
the Bible has something to say about
this you know watching these kind of
shows where this is portrayed. First
Thessalonians, it says, "Abstain from
all appearance of evil, and the very God
of peace sanctify you holy, and I pray
God, your whole spirit and soul and body
be preserved blameless unto the coming
of our Lord Jesus Christ." Right? This
is our God's purpose for us. And is this
sanctification process where God wants
to preserve our bodies blameless unto
the Lord Jesus Christ and our spirit and
our soul. Is that really what's
happening here? If they open a show like
love, joy, peace, sex, dance. Well, I
think it's interesting that it uses the
word from all appearances. Yeah. So,
it's it's even making a distinguishing
fact about like not just the act of
those things, but even just in in
portraying those things. Well, there
goes movies and this all out the window
if they're portraying evil even though
they're not doing it. You know what I
mean? And the Bible talks about that
those who enjoy watching other people
sin, it's like you are sinning yourself,
right? It says it says abstain from that
too. So, the thing that's most talked
about, and I blurred this, is she first
kissed a male dancer, and then she went
on to kiss a female dancer, and then
there was another female that cut really
close to her mouth and they didn't kiss.
But hey, we know what the doll
represents. So, everyone's talking about
this and, you know, it's not like she
just accidentally fell into this. This
was choreographed like she knew what she
was getting into. It kind of reminds me
of a couple years back. I think it was
the MGV Music Video Awards when I was
younger. This came out with uh Madonna
who performed with Britney Spears and
Christina Aguilera and then kissed both
of them on the lips. Madonna is known to
make statements such as, "Yeah,
regarding homosexuality, oh, if they
keep seeing it and keep seeing it,
eventually it'll just get secretly
aroused by it and it'll just be accepted
by society." I think there's a couple of
things going on here. If you look at the
imagery, you're seeing essentially
transhumanism.
Because they're, you know, their bodies
are all like circuit boards and all that
kind of thing. So true. Transhumanism,
you know, you're essentially doing away
very much with the concept of gender.
Everything becomes androgynous and
there's no distinction between sexes,
which means you can blur those lines in
that philosophy when it comes to love
and sexuality and all of that. There's
there the transhuman movement removes
the consequence of sin because if you
could figure out how to basically pop
your head off and put it on some sort of
machine and then keep that machine being
updated, you essentially wouldn't die.
And then if God says the wages of sin
are death, yeah, to do what they want
without the consequences of it is
ultimately removing God because you're
removing his creation. So you're
removing him as creator. M you know
there is no why do you need God for yeah
that's an interesting point robots and
you know those kind of things. This is
true and that's very much the theme
throughout this whole performance like
right from the get-go they were like
we're entering an AI technological kind
of space. M so and then also talking
about transhumanism
um the idea of being both male and
female uh that androgynist yeah that
originates from paganism which even
people in the LGBTQ recognize that's the
history of it that's just what happened
so kind of interesting that then this is
what's happening in that context but I
want to show you guys the clip not to
show you guys the clip but I wanted you
guys to listen to the lyrics that's
being sung and then we'll look at the
lyrics itself of the the song that's
actually being played during this
section of the performance.
When you're not
[Applause]
here, baby,
did you guys hear it was being sung?
Yeah, it's a it's a popular song by uh
Terry Teddy. Petty Teddy Slims. Yeah.
Lose control. Well, control is You
brought up the fruits of the spirit is
one of the fruits of the spirit. Yeah.
Self-control. Yeah. And this is being
like in love with one person, passed to
another person, passed to another
person, you know, and she's just getting
passed down the line. Yeah. Yeah. So,
the lyrics say, "Something's got a hold
of me lately. No, I don't know myself
anymore. Feels like the walls are all
closing in and the devil's knocking at
my door. Out of my mind. How many times
did I tell you I'm no good at being
alone? Yeah, it's taken a toll on me.
Trying my best to keep from tearing the
skin off my bones. Don't you know? I
lose control when you're not next to me.
I'm falling apart right in front of you.
Can't you see? I lose control when
you're not next to me. Hm. Yeah, you're
breaking my heart, baby. You make a mess
of me. This is being played while she is
making out with a woman and a man and
another woman and another man.
appropriate album cover. And um you
know, it it
really makes that other person God in
your life. Mhm. Cuz if you don't have
control without them, you're just a
mess. You know, you're saying, "I can't
control my actions. I can't control who
I am." It's like, "There's no help for
me. You're the only one that can do it."
Well, you've essentially put that person
above God, and there's
no there's no picture of the gospel
there. Mhm. Who would like to be married
to a a spouse that says, "I can't
control myself, and every time you walk
out of the house, I'm sorry, I lost
control." Yeah. I just fall to pieces.
Yeah. It destroys people's lives. You
have to have self-control in a marriage.
Yeah. And I think this is the wild thing
is that real biblical Christian marriage
doesn't look like this. It doesn't look
like the movies. This is like this
dramatic form of what they call love
like in the beginning of the
performance, which it's not. It's lust.
It's passion. It's not love. You know,
love has self-control, right? And like
you you guys are saying, and and love is
not like every time I'm walk out the
door or my husband is like going on a
trip and gone for two weeks. I don't
fall to pieces. I love my husband. I
miss him, but but I don't fall to
pieces. That's dramatic to the point
where it's fake. And there's also blame
implied. You know, you make a mess of
me, it's it's your fault. It's your
fault. Yeah, manipulation because I
can't control myself. So, if you're
gone, it's it's it's essentially your
fault that I can't control myself. This
just to me sounds like someone has some
serious mental problems that honestly I
mean this kindly needs to seek out some
therapy if this is actually what your
relationship looks like. Yeah,
absolutely. Yeah. And then also kind of
crazy, right, that it says, "And the
devil's knocking at my door and then I
can't I don't have control." She's
making out with all these people when
the song plays that's singing about the
devil knocking on the door and there's
no control. So, um, and that's even more
interesting that like Jesus used the the
the thing about knocking on the door of
the heart. You know what I mean? Yeah.
Yeah. I mean, that's like a very
spiritual concept. So true. So true.
[Applause]
Okay. So, everybody is in there. They're
like, "Woo!" And there's like she's
playing as seductress. They're throwing
sex on the screen. Like, obviously
putting it in there, right? They're not
talking about gender. No. No. Yeah. You
know, back in the day when Elvis Presley
was, you know, becoming popular and they
would live stream his concerts, they had
to only film him from the hip up because
his dances were too sensual. You know,
they were too sexual. and they and they
would cut it off the live stream of the
broadcast if it was, you know, if it
showed on screen. And then today, we
don't even care about that that anymore.
You know, she's, you know, basically
half naked with the word sex on there.
Who cares anymore, right? Just to show
how far we've gone, we've come from
desensitized. Desensitized. Yeah. Yeah.
And then this is our concept of love. I
mean, and we brought up the concept
before like marriage is really designed
not to necessarily make you happy.
That's not really the purpose of
marriage, right? Right. It's to refine
you and it was God's chosen vehicle to
basically make you draw closer to him
when you rub with somebody else and you
have to problem solve and you have every
decision you make isn't just for
yourself. It's for somebody else that's
in your in your immediate circle. And so
there's many concepts about like what a
marriage looks like and this just goes
against all of those.
So, the song that she's playing as she's
doing this and flashing sex on the
screen and there she goes into this
really erotic dance is uh a song by
Charlie CXC featuring Billy Eyish. It's
called Guess. I had to blur the lyrics.
It is so vile. It's openly publicly
describing sexual things about the
woman's private parts. And we all know
that Billy Alish once put us out a song
called Lunch that talks about that same
concept. So this is not new. But again,
it's this idea of
break. I'm sorry. Do we know each other?
It seems like maybe we've met before. I
don't know. This is uh it's awkward
though, just as much for me as it is for
you. I really wish I had a conversation
[Music]
starter. Oh, hey. Oh, what's on my
shirt? Yeah, this is the story of the
three angels message from Revelation 14.
Wow, that totally worked. You know, if
you have trouble starting conversations
like me, maybe you should try LightWare.
[Music]
But again, it's this idea of no
boundaries, no like do what thou wilt.
So many so many people look up to these
artists. So many young women look up to
Billy Isish. And then she goes on on the
Rolling Stones and puts out an article
about what she does in her bedroom on
her private, you know, stuff that nobody
should should know. Then she has a big
fan base like that. Yeah. And it's like
I mean what are we teaching? What is the
message being put? Whether you know it
or not the message is being planted
right there. Yeah. Is not the one that
should be planted because the Bible says
but beholding we become changed. Right.
So you know and the Bible also says in
first Corinthians do not know that the
unrighteous will not inherit the kingdom
of God. Do not be deceived. Neither
fornicators, nor idolattors, nor
adulterers, nor homosexuals, nor
sodomites, nor thieves, nor covetous,
nor drunkards, nor revilers, nor
extortioners will inherit the kingdom of
God. And such were some of you, but you
were washed, but you were sanctified.
But you were justified in the name of
the Lord Jesus by the spirit of our God.
Like he wants to cleanse us. He wants to
change our hearts. He's not saying stay
here. He's saying, "Such worse some of
you, but if you come to me, I will wash
you clean of all of your sins, no matter
what you've done."
[Music]
Did you guys see what happened? and what
she was doing. It was joy. It was
written joy on the first clip. It was
written on the second clip. There's
nothing but there was nothing on there.
It's just like but it just doesn't
match. So it's she's there's joy on the
screen and she goes pa and everybody
falls around her dead and she's pow into
the audience. Joy.
What? Yeah. Like what kind of messages
are being put in your brain? And I' I'd
love to be a fly on the wall when they
come up with this concept and try to sit
around a table and go like we're going
to do this. Let's have the word joy on
the screen and let's shoot each other. I
mean, it's just like, yeah, what in the
world? Yeah, but like they know why
they're doing this. Why do you have
advertisements with, you know, um,
subliminal messaging or why do you have
shows and they put a Coca-Cola in there
or they put this in there, they put
that? They know subliminal messaging
works. M so when you put joy on a screen
which is not even that subliminal and
you shoot people that's subliminal
messaging that's like hey we should
connect these two so if you want to find
joy which again is a fruit of the spirit
and that does not come from God to shoot
people that's not joy from God that's
from Satan that's satanic but hey you
should shoot people if you want to find
joy that's basically what they're saying
the Bible says in Proverbs my son do not
walk in the way with them keep your foot
from their path for their feet run to
evil and they make haste to shed blood.
Clearly this is not something that we
should be watching. Then uh second
Timothy says, "But know this that in the
last days perilous times will come, for
men will be lovers of themselves, lovers
of money, boasters, proud, blasphemers,
disobedient to parents, unthankful,
unholy, unloving, unforgiving,
slanderers, without self-control,
brutal, despicers of good good traitors,
headstrong, hotty, lovers of pleasures
rather than lovers of God." We are
living in the last days. Clearly, we are
living in the last days. I believe Jesus
is coming very soon. And so I I think
this shows us that we need to ask
ourselves the question of like what are
we spending our time on? Are we actually
allowing God to work in us that
sanctification process where he says,
"Hey, I want to give you the real fruits
of the of the Holy Spirit, not this fake
wannabe copy stuff that Satan puts out,
but the real fruits of the spirit. I
want to change you. I want to sanctify
your heart." And that's not just for
people who are already Christian. This
is for everyone. This is for JLo. Like
God wants her heart, too. Then second
Peter says, "And turning the cities of
Sodom and Gomorrah into ashes, condemned
them to destruction, making them an
example to those who afterward would
live ungodly and delivered righteous
Lot, who was oppressed by the filthy
conduct of the wicked." So, we know that
in the Bible, in the Old Testament,
there was this city called those two
cities actually called Sodom and
Gomorrah, uh, where Lot, Abraham's
nephew, lived. And God destroyed those
cities and he saved Lot out of it. Um,
and we know that if you read the story,
there were men who wanted to have sex
with angels who they perceived as this
other men, right? Yeah. To the point
where they surround the house and like,
come, you know, come out and we're gonna
have our way with you. I mean, you
haven't really seen that in an open
setting in this world yet, but it's
going to happen soon. The Bible says,
"This time's going to be like no other,
and it was bad back there. What worse is
that going to get to today?" Mhm. You
know, exactly. And and I think that we
are slowly, well, actually, not even
slowly, speedingly headed in that
direction as we see all of this stuff
happening around, like you said, Felipe,
that when when Elvis Presley was around
Just for him moving his crotch in a
certain way was considered
inappropriate, which yes, it is. And
nowadays, we see people with just three
stars on their body and that supposedly
covers something, right? Isn't she like
60? She's she's up there. I think she's
50.
I don't think she's hit 60 yet. You
know, the Bible has a lot to say about
nakedness. In fact, there's a few times
that the Bible mentions this exact like
kind of terminology that says, you know,
that you not be found naked. Adam and
Eve sinned once. It wasn't like they had
this history of sin, but once eating a
piece of fruit, which by all means, like
eating a piece of fruit or dancing
around on a stage naked, like which
one's which one's more impactful to you,
right? And that piece of fruit caused
Adam and Eve to feel naked and ashamed.
And so what I think Hollywood is doing
right now is it's circling around the
drain, you know, and it's going like,
let's reorientate everybody to not feel
shameful when you're naked. I mean,
going up front of thousands and
thousands and thousands from the whole
world, right? What if that was your mom?
Yeah. I mean, that would be weird,
right? Well, they will come to a point
where they won't care if that's your mom
or not. I'm guessing her children cuz
she has two children, twins, and are 17.
Yeah. I'm guessing being raised in that
home and environment they think it's
normal. I mean, for me, how would I feel
if that was my daughter? You know, it
would break my heart. And so, like,
yeah, it's wild. It's wild that the
whole world is being sold the wrong
picture of love. And um I think we are
definitely living in the last days. Mhm.
So, you mentioned Sodom and Gomorrah.
And I think it's interesting something
that Jesus says, "Assuredly I say to
you, it will be more tolerable for the
land of Sodom and Gomorrah in the day of
judgment than for that city." He's
actually delivering a message as part of
Matthew chapter 10 and saying when we
don't listen to the gospel, when we
don't listen to essentially his words,
what we have now, we have more
information than those people had.
We are more accountable. No excuse. More
accountable than those people. So we can
we can cast judgment on Sodom and
Gomorrah. But Jesus is saying it's, you
know, it's more tolerable for them. The
condemnation that they had is more more
tolerable than the condemnation that
will exist at the end of time for us if
we do things contrary to
what is written in the word. So, so in
other words, it says we have so much
information. There's no excuse. There's
so much light. There's no excuse. Yeah.
There's no excuse. So, as much as we we
look back at them and say, "Man, they
were bad people." Well, everybody's
we're all bad people, you know, if not
for if not for God. You know, going back
to this verse here where it says uh Lot
uh who who was oppressed by the filthy
and conduct of the wicked. Take take a
look at this verse from Proverbs. Do not
envy the oppressor and choose none of
his ways. In other words, those who
oppress Lot, those who are part of like
the Sodom and Gomorrah system, it says
don't be part of that. Mhm. None of his
ways. None. Do the exact opposite. But
you know, yes, it does talk about a
judgment is going to come. And a
judgment is a good thing because God
wants to eradicate sin, right? But he's
not sitting there thinking, "Ah, I can't
wait to burn those people on hell." you
know, like you see those like signs like
uh I remember just like vividly in my
brain when we went to Bakersville,
California like 10 years ago, I think
when we went to a big conference in
Texas 2015 that we drove through
Bakersville and there showed us a sign
that says you think Bakersville is hot,
hell is
hotter. That's not how God is. Right? It
says in Ezekiel, "Say to them, as I
live, says the Lord God, I have no
pleasure in the death of the wicked, but
that the wicked turn from his way and
live. Turn, turn from your evil ways,
for why should you die, oh house of
Israel?" I think the moment that people
realize that they have exchanged their
golden ticket for heaven for the
pleasures of this world is going to be a
very sad moment. Absolutely. And and you
know, I spent time in the world. They
spent 10 years plus doing my own thing
and focusing on me and and trying to do
what these people here were doing. And
I'll tell you from my own personal
experience and I didn't have the success
that they did. It's it's not as cracked
up to be what everyone sees from the
outside. These people I mean obviously
you can see the court cases and things
that have come up. They are subjected to
some pretty dark things. Yep. And so you
know if you actually lived in a normal
Christian life you sleep well at night
time. These people probably do not. Mhm.
And so, um, I I I think, you know, it's
time that we, you know, make a stand
against the filthiness of this world. If
you were a Christian and you really want
to do what God wants you to do, don't
engage in this kind of stuff. Don't pay
attention to this kind of stuff. I feel
like I'm I'm I'm removed from it. Even
listening to um you break this down,
it's like like I at one point in my
life, I would have been attracted to
those kind of things. And then now it's
like, "Oh man, I I I want to go to
heaven." Like, "I really want to go to
heaven." Like, "What can we do now to
help other people want to go to heaven?"
Amen. Yeah. Pray for them, don't pay for
them. Yeah. Yeah. Exactly. Yeah. Yeah.
And then, uh, lastly, second Peter says,
"The Lord is not slack concerning his
promise, as some count slackness, but is
long-suffering toward us, not willing
that any should perish, but at all
should come to repentance." God's not
sitting there waiting for till he can
zap somebody. He's like, I want to save
everybody and I want to bring them with
me into the kingdom, but it's our
decision, right? We have to decide, are
we going to give into the Holy Spirit's
prompings? This call that's for
everybody. No matter what you've done,
no matter how far you've gone, he wants
to save you. And he's waiting, knocking
on your the door of your heart, like you
said. And I want to point something out
that this is this verse is from the New
Testament. But the one we read before in
in Ezekiel, that's from the Old
Testament. People like to argue that,
oh, God wasn't really as merciful in the
Old Testament. He was really, you know,
oh, you sin, you die. Uh the the
sentence was brought up right there. But
we can see that as we read in Ezekiel,
God did not change from the Old
Testament to the New Testament. He's
always been um long-suffering. He's
never wanted anyone to die. Mhm. Right.
So, you know, we we look at to to come
to what Scotty said as well about, you
know, these people have to go through a
lot of stuff. And something that I like
to think once in a while and remind
myself is, you know, what's the last
time I prayed for one of these
celebrities? When was the last time we
prayed for Jennifer Lopez? When was the
last time we prayed for Diddy? You know,
we had an episode recently on the Diddy
trial. Was the last time we prayed for
any of the victims from the Diddy case
or or anyone that is watching so that
they can actually come to repentance
because Jesus said there's no greater
love than this that we should lay down
our life for our friend. And you know,
in one way or another, they're also
God's children. They're also someone
that we should pray for. Mhm. Good
point. If you like this video, like,
subscribe, and hit the notification bell
so you know when we launch new videos.
And drop a comments below, and we'll try
to get back to you if we can. What?
Say that again. No. No. I don't know
what to say.
[Music]